un manifestante Pro democracia paraguas
en mano y por una buena razón Los
cañones de Agua de la policía israelí
están funcionando A toda máquina en el
centro de tel aviv el jueves miles de
manifestantes en todo el país pidieron
La retirada de una reforma judicial que
pretende aumentar el poder de los cargos
electos sobre el poder judicial y de la
que ya se aprobó un primer texto en
acnético
no recibió el mandato de cambiar las
reglas del sistema en Israel Bibi
recibió el mandato de gobernar según las
reglas del juego el mero hecho de que
intente cambiar el sistema es
inaceptable a partir de ahora en Israel
será mucho más difícil destituir al
Primer Ministro en la práctica el jefe
del gobierno ya no podrá ser declarado
incapaz por conflicto de intereses o por
razones puramente judiciales esto es una
bendición para Benjamín neta ñau
enredado en varios escándalos sobre
método de corrupción tras la votación el
Primer Ministro se expresó públicamente
y dijo que quería poner fin a las
divisiones sin hacer ningún anuncio a la
oposición
por el bien de nuestro pueblo por el
bien de nuestro país Haré todo lo que
esté en mis manos para alcanzar una
solución
la participación de metaniau en las
reformas seria ilegal según la fiscal
general de Israel por el momento el
descontento va en aumento como en el
ejército donde cada vez más reservista
se niegan a formarse una situación que
preocupa al ministro de defensa por el
riesgo que este proyecto supondría para
la seguridad nacional